passengers are having a complete
meltdown more and more at airports
because flying has gotten so bad but get
this illegal migrants are getting a free
pass my next guest exclusively captured
a TSA notice at Miami International
Airport he was as stunned as you're
about to be where migrants who don't
have IDs can get through security and
they can even say no to having their
photo taken you can't the sign reading
this photo capture is voluntary you may
decline to have your photo taken if you
not
TSA officer CBP one only CBP one only
verifies the information you previously
provided to the CBP it will not store
your information my next guest says this
is a plan to destroy America and this is
the picture you took and that we were
just sharing the screen with it Dave
Rubin host of the ruin report creator of
locals great to see you it's good to be
with you Brian I was flying to see you
in Gutfeld tonight to uh to in that
order please in that order obviously and
the funny thing is I don't know how long
that picture has been up I don't know
how many people have walked by it you
know you go to the airport there's signs
up everywhere about all sorts of stuff
and everyone kind of ignores everything
and the line was going slow and I
happened to look at it and then
immediately I thought this is absolutely
insane and I was on the pre-tsa line so
somehow they're letting the migrants go
through the pre-tsa line which by the
way they did make me take my shoes off
for and take my sweatshirt off for and
I'm fairly certain that to get on a
plane as an American citizen you need an
ID so nothing nothing surprises me at
this point and yes I do believe at this
point it is a it is a plan to destroy
America this is not unintentional at
this point but do you think what destroy
America you get a bunch of people you
don't know millions of people you don't
know and let them go anywhere they want
yeah I I would say in essence that would
destroy America you know we are a nation
of laws I mean to Loosely quote Trump
you either have a country or you don't
so if you just let people in with good
intentions or not I mean the road to
hell is paav with good intentions if you
let these people in and we don't know
what their beliefs are we don't know why
is it that so many of them seem like
they're about 25 to 35 men you know when
you're fleeing a war you're usually
bringing the women and children where
are all the pictures of Ellis Island our
our ancestors that that came with one
bag and you know nothing else uh we're
seeing fighting age men come here and
they're giving privileges that our own
citizens don't have and the response
online has been off the charts here's
what TSA statement say was to Fox News
quote it is used it is used by TSA to
initiate a thorough multisource
identification verification process
culminating with enhanced screening at
the checkpoints before an individual is
allowed to secure uh to a secure area of
an airport any non-citizen who poses a
threat to the public safety or national
security is detained by DHS or turned
over to another Agency for investigation
and prosecution any individual who poses
a public security threat is not
permitted by the TSA into the secure
area of any airport I mean that's
incredible double speak there anyone who
poses a threat well how do we know if
they POS a threat and you're telling me
that those agents right there they're
going to they're going to actually
surmise whether that person is causing a
threat or is potentially going to cause
a threat it's complete nonsense why
would you leave it up to the m the
migrant they call them why would you
leave it up to the migrant to decide
whether they should have their picture
taken or not when I go pre-tsa you know
you not only show them your ID but they
take a digital picture of you right
there why are why are they getting it's
not even privileges exactly why are they
getting uh allowed out of the system
while we are all being put into the
system and you're not only outraged Dave
Ruben so are the people that follow you
I mean what kind of response did you get
online well I had a feeling it was going
to kind of take off but it really I mean
senators were tweeting it out and it's
obviously been covered on Fox and all
the networks but again I don't know how
many other people walk by that sign
every day and just don't bother reading
it it's not like I was out there doing
you know private investigative work I'm
just a citizen just like you are who was
going to jump on a plane to come here
and see you and Greg and and I saw that
and put it up there and I think that's
also part of the problem you know so
many things are happening at once and
every day you're seeing the flood of
migrants come in and people can't even
absorb the level of craziness that we're
dealing with in the country right now so
you walk by you just see a sign you
don't bother reading it but all I did
was shine a little light on it that's it
and that's it you do have that touch I
suppose one the reason you got that
touch you work with Jordan Peterson for
a while yeah so Jordan Peterson
evidently is wrestling having a
wrestling match with the Canadian
authorities who are trying to take his
psychiatric license away because they
don't like the way he handles Social
Media they don't like the way he tweets
he's a mean Tweeter so they want him to
do mandatory
uh social media training in order to
retain his license and he lost his
appeal but he came out with this tweet
congratulations Ontario you won that
round mark my words however the war has
barely been started there is nothing you
can take from me that I am unwilling to
lose they have picked the fight with the
wrong guy you know Jordan Peterson so he
was a practicing clinical psychologist
years ago that was his original job then
he was of course a professor at Harvard
now author and speaker and and and you
know the things that we all know him for
uh traveling the world and and getting
people to stand up straight with their
shoulders back and everything else the
idea that they are going to take away
his clinician license whether he wants
to be in practice or not is irrelevant
at this point that they're saying to him
you cannot be in practice because we
don't like the way you tweet I mean CL
alarm alarmism he was saying that TR uh
the transgender ideology they didn't
like that the Canadian government didn't
like that he was doing this well he's
also using the expertise that he has
gained as a clinician to talk about the
issue of trans identity I mean that's
that's the thing now you may not like
some once in a while if he tweets
something that feels maybe a little bit
overboard this or that or the other
thing but I believe although they don't
have the free uh First Amendment they do
have some level of free speech in Canada
and he will not stop fighting them he
will not stop if he has to leave Canada
all together to to strengthen the fight
he will do that you know him yeah I they
will not win this fight Trudeau will not
beat Jordan Peterson I promise you that
Brian and I will say this uh Dave the
other thing is I'm having less and less
respect for the Canadian government
between the truckers the more I find out
the less I like but I always love having
you in thanks so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else